alright what's up people there you have
it an hour and a half of the most boring
political talk in the history of modern
American politics I mean that that was
just that was painful for for a lot of
reasons I'm getting a lot of [ __ ] on
Twitter at the moment because i was more
critical of cain than i was a pent my
main takeaway i'll start with my main
takeaway by the way i got my I got my
team here working with me so you can
tweet questions at me you can comment in
YouTube right there if you're on patreon
you get first priority so you can
comment on patreon and Facebook whatever
we'll find you I'll be happy to answer
questions and talk about the whole thing
going with the the stone IPA tonight
they do not sponsor us but they could if
they wanted to all right basically that
was incredibly boring and the thing is
it shouldn't have been boring because
most people in the country are disgusted
with both of our choices right you've
got the fringe that love Hillary in the
fringe that love Trump but then everyone
else inside their voting them for them
but grudgingly or not going to vote or
not happy in general or doesn't know
what so these people should have had
this should have had some value this
should have been important at some level
especially when you factor in that Trump
i think is 78 Hillary 69 I mean these
are not young people that are going to
be President especially when you factor
in that the country is so polarized and
that we have two people who I don't
think are the most ethical candidates
ever in the history of the United States
impeachment could be possible I mean one
of these two guys could the president is
my point so this had opportunity to get
into it you know first I thought the the
moderator was just a little stiff it was
just question and then nothing so it was
just dry and also the camera angles were
weird so they were never really looking
at each other they were kind of looking
off and towards the sides of the
television so it didn't make for great
TV just you know aesthetically like that
but anyway so first off I'll start with
came first you know for all the people
who don't like when Trump interrupt
um he interrupted relentlessly and
endlessly and with that like half-ass
smile on his face and what I do really
what I more so didn't like about him is
not the interrupting it's a debate so I
like seeing healthy in trucking I
thought in the presidential debate last
week there were some moments of
interruption that I thought some of the
best stuff happened it allows for a good
comeback if you got it we should be
afraid of that we're you know on one
hand we all complain they all act like
robots and they're all about talking
points in ba ba ba and then the second
there is some human emotion versus I
they're interrupting a letter
complaining it that makes no sense I
would much rather have I would get the
moderator out of the way and have them
just go at it just go at it for an hour
net or have several different types of
debates so you have one with the
moderator you have one without a
moderator you have one where they have
to just answer questions from the crab
you have one and Thunderdome whatever it
is that's that's what I would hey so
Cain interrupted a lot that in and of
itself I don't have a problem with just
as I didn't have a real problem with it
when when Trump did it last week I
thought the bigger issue McCain was that
he just kept repeating all of the things
that everyone says about Trump that are
like sort of half truths or not quite
truths the thing about Putin being a
strong leader I mean I saw and when
Trump said that to matt lauer he
basically was like he's a strong leader
that doesn't mean I like him that
doesn't mean I think he's good for his
people something to that effect like
everything he said was just kind of not
not exactly the way it is he wasn't
saying all Mexicans like all of these
things that's not defending any of the
things the Trump says but came that Kane
just come out came off as just that that
smug elitist yeah just whatever pence on
the other hand is like a walking ambien
commercial he's extremely calm almost to
the point of sleeping and there's
something that comes off I think look
very insincere about him but a lot when
I said tweeted that a lot of people were
pushing back and he sayin he's just
measured and confident and whatever um I
don't know a tremendous amount about him
beyond what most people know about him
but yeah there's something that seems a
little a little sniff or whatever they
needed just some good healthy like
debate about ideas I thought Kane's best
moment was when
he said that he doesn't let his personal
faith get involved in politics and what
he was talking about the death penalty
you know pence if you're a right to life
person Pence's answer on that was was
was good to be solid it was profound
that's not the way I feel about it I can
understand the way when people think
about that I'm not some crazy person
that tries to demonize every single
person that is not pro choice although I
personally am pro-choice and I agree
more with what Tim Cain said about
letting a woman choose I would let a
woman choose and it's a horrible
decision and it's not something women
are not having a boring parties they
don't want to have proportions generally
speaking so I thought they both had a
couple good moments company was just
nothing like there was just nothing here
when there was real opportunity and a
few people were tweeting at me that
saying that this proves why Trump is so
good for the election because at least
there's some excitement versus just
seeing two standard politicians do their
due their standard thing anyway so we'll
do some questions comments thoughts all
that um yeah it was they didn't give us
much I just don't think they gave us
much Cain saying that we're safer from
terrorism now I thought it was a strange
line I don't think anyone feels that way
and his is reasoning behind that was
that Osama bin Laden is dead which is
true but Osama bin Laden wasn't the only
terrorists and you cut off the head of
the snake if you had to rise right and
then and then the thing about the
offense is taken a selfie right now the
way the kid and then and then his other
thing was about the the Iran nuclear
deal I thought pence did make a good
point about their a nuclear deal which
even if you're a hundred percent for the
deal when the deal expires I don't
remember offhand what year it is I think
some in maybe 12 or 15 years someone can
comment down below let me know then
there are no regulations anymore so it
was it's a temporary stopping if you
believe if you believe it works that
this thing that they signed works that
it's a temporary stoppage not a
permanent stoppage um beyond that you
know can definitely pit pens his biggest
problem for sure was defending some of
the things that that Trump has said as i
said before canvas
studying them in a way that wasn't quite
honest I don't think but Pence needed a
better reaction to that and that's also
a tripped up trump last week is that he
can't really defend some of the crazy
things he says I'm off script that's why
everybody loves me but then I have to
defend some of the things even if it's
taken slightly out of context that's
part of politics too so you got to grow
up and be able to defend it um I would
say the neck winner here if there's a
litter and first off you know all the
all the polls that you're going to see
now on all the networks they can tell
you who wanted lost a win and a loss
means jack [ __ ] unless an actual person
change their vote so how many people do
you think actually change their vote
because of this I mean anyone watching
this right now I'd love to know the
YouTube comments right to Center
anywhere where you watch my Twitter did
you change your vote for Hillary Clinton
or for Donald Trump because of what
something that you just saw on the BP
debate this they notice the the vp
debate and the VP choice in general
barely tix anything one way or another
so I don't sense that this is going to
do anything I'd say in terms of wins and
losses look everyone is so on their own
team at the moment and I really do try
my best to not be that I try to see
things as objectively as possible but
everyone saw on their team that yeah
okay you like Clinton you liked him like
you're like Trump you like pence okay
fine i would say basically though it was
a net win interns were just playing the
game right it was a net win for pence
because you came with all of his
smugness and his little little attacks
and he comes off as little whiny or
something um i would say that by pence
being a little calmer or something that
made that it was away in that way does
that change one single vote in this
entire country of 300 something million
people not so sure all right we got you
want to throw some questions oh we got
questions coming in right here okay
faith questions why do they still exist
so that's a good one and it's such a
damn shame you know we are not governed
by faith and here i will give tim kaine
credit for his answer as i did a second
ago what he said is I of fate I was
Irish Catholic brought up in the church
Jesuits something or another blah blah
blah but in terms of public policy
law the land was for the death penalty
and I didn't let my my personal
religious feelings get involved so
that's a perfectly fine answer um it
shouldn't be it shouldn't we should not
be talking about faith at all and I
think a lot of countries look at us and
see this as something that's really
really silly you are entitled to believe
whatever you want whatever you want as
long as you're not infringing on the
rights of other people and actually
you're allowed to believe in things that
you print other rights because you can't
put them into action right so that's
where tim kaine made a nice distinction
I believe in a certain thing but as a
public policy maker and as an executive
i'm not going to instill it on other
people so okay nice mom right as a
general rule though we should be
governed by one document and it's not
the Bible and it ain't the Quran yet and
it ain't the New Testament it's the
Constitution and in the Constitution we
have a separation of church and state
and that's it so this whole thing about
faith yeah if you drive you derive some
some joy in life or some inner peace in
life because of faith and then good for
you and I don't think but I don't think
you're a better person for having faith
and I don't think I just thought I wish
we didn't have to focus on it the way
the beginning that being said we only
talked about it for about three minutes
here and I don't think I don't think
there was any sense that that when do we
talk about it at all was there any faith
question in the first tomato that's for
sure um someone said I liked it I liked
your show but he's pissed at the left
and it appears to occasionally blind him
human yeah possibly possibly I am so fed
up with my what I thought or what I
think is my side what I've seen happen
to the left related to free speech and
screaming racist Islamophobe biggity all
of that stuff transpo all that garbage
at people silencing people from talking
lying about people um dishonest attacks
all that I've seen so much of it from my
guys that does not mean the right
doesn't do it it doesn't mean the right
doesn't do it but what would it matter
if a liberal was just attacking the
right relentlessly everyone's doing I've
been trying to clean up my side so if
occasionally i come off as a little uh
not even handed i suppose or whatever or
heavy-handed I'm not perfect I do
my best I really do try to be fair um
but I think that's a valid criticism and
I'm not perfect um believe it or not I'm
not perfect and I accept that I came to
that conclusion to my feet uh all right
let's see um Dave do you think the
moderator was fair yeah I mean I didn't
see anything one way or another she was
actually completely benign and barely
barely part of the operation uh okay
what else do we got here um what about
Jill Stein you know look at this point
with the third party thing mostly
theater watching this you probably saw
my video on Gary Johnson and I
subsequently explain my feelings about
Gary since then he has made just epic am
vector epic f he's making pockets look
dumb I don't like that um yeah the guy
he's just really crumpled and its really
disappointing he doesn't seem to have
like a seventh graders basic knowledge
of geography or just how politics works
or anything it's just it's very
disappointing for me but my whole point
is that I wanted to get him to fifteen
percent to get another idea in the
debate by the way I would have been for
trying to get Jill Stein to fifteen
percent if she had had even a remote
chance at that point she was bawling at
like two percent a month ago and gary
was not eight percent so there was a
remote chance he could get to 15 i would
say at this point neither one of them
are going anywhere they'll both siphon
off some boats the interesting thing is
i don't know which way gary johnson
siphons some boat sophomore from so jill
stein if she gets two percent most
likely that's at the expense of Hillary
or its people that just weren't gonna
vote but for Gary Johnson he's expressed
admiration for Hillary Allah so if you
really don't like Hillary let's say you
say Hillary's really corrupt or she's
you know gone to war more than you like
and all that so you like the idea of
libertarianism you might be inclined to
vote for Gary Johnson instead of Hillary
traditionally you would think that a
libertarian candidate would draw more
from a conservative more from someone on
the right I don't know that that's gonna
happen this time I'm really not sure but
I but I am
I feel bad sort of about what happened
why Gary Johnson because I just this was
the year if there ever was going to be a
year for a third party maybe not to win
this year but to really show people guys
mother [ __ ] wake up there's some
other choices here besides Clinton and
Trump this was the year and instead the
libertarians I'm unfortunately and they
didn't have many better choices by the
way but they put up a guy who is not a
particularly good libertarian didn't
even fight for most libertarian values
and really who had very little knowledge
about a lot of things that that most
people could have am I gonna have to run
in 2020 what a pain um let's see uh
comes to that point somebody said I
thought that Austin Peterson was the
Libertarian candidate who could have
could have swung me from Trump so here a
true libertarian I've gone back and
forth with Austin Peterson a little bit
i think we had a book and something
happened but he tried to get the
nomination from gary johnson he's a
younger guy more of a pure libertarian I
you know he's one of these guys I don't
even think he's for driver's licenses
which i bought the Libertarians floor in
the past but i'll try to get him on and
you know he's an interesting area um
let's see hey dave was tonight's debate
gross and racist um there was nothing
particularly gross and racist about it I
would say the only thing gross about it
was that King just repeatedly kept
saying things that were not really
quotes by Trump now yes Trump does these
things all the time too but if you want
your side to be better than they have to
behave better and I don't think he won I
don't think he won much support you know
you needed said look these got both of
them are unlikable right so truck I know
a lot of people like a lot of like Trump
like the supporters that like Trump
really love I don't see a lot of love
behind the Clinton operation but maybe
it maybe it's there and I'm just not
seeing it because there's not as vocal
in the online world that I'm part of but
clearly what Clinton needed was more of
a likable guy or not he usually comes
off as somewhat like speaks in Spanish
ideals meet but fine but he did not come
off as likable tonight and I do think so
I think that kind of kind of answer okay
let's see a couple people have asked
me to get on ron paul i would love to
get around Paul on we've been trying you
guys know we're partnered up with learn
Liberty now they're sending us against a
month and I think I think they're
working on him and we've tried a bunch
of different ways if you know rampal
tell him to swing on by I'd like to I
would love to talk to him I think it
would be a great conversation um you
know interestingly look the vice
president barring something horrific
happening borrowing a medical problem or
assassination or or an impeachment the
BP pretty much does nothing what is Joe
by really done in these last eight years
you know um watch beep I mean the vice
president's not doing that much so you
know but even before Joe Biden you know
actually a well balanced I guess not a
good example because that was one case
where the VP didn't do a lot because
Dick Cheney obviously was the architect
for a lot of what george w bush was
doing i tend to think that with Donald
Trump and with Hillary Clinton they
would not cede that kind of power to BP
um somebody asks what's the status of
Thomas soul so he's he has a new book
out and we finally got the good contact
we reached out and like we made a little
headway I'm not totally sure where it
stands right now but we're in contact at
least so that's where it starts um yeah
so hopefully hopefully it'll happen um
let's see what else you know look the we
were so in this thing right now we're 34
days away right now from this thing only
been pounding at it pounding at it it
was interesting how many people online
was saying lied number I don't really
know anything about this guy or I could
see anything about this guy or they for
the first time really seeing them um
which just goes to show it's like we're
so caught up in the sensationalism that
really talking about the issues you know
isn't doesn't happen that much you know
one way if you wanted to slam pense if
you want to really be pensive and Kane
mr. real opportunity Pence has been
hugely antigay hugely antigay and pushed
for anti-gay legislation all that
regardless of your personal feelings
about gay people it's a it's a non-issue
at this point that gay people should be
treated equally and have the same right
to marry and that's really all gay
people wanted we didn't want extra
rights we just wanted
same rights um so I think Cain missed a
real opportunity and he could have done
is related to the whole thing about
faith because obviously Pence's feelings
about gay people somehow formed by his
faith you know I guess not that you
should love every person equally or
something didn't Jesus say something
like that but that you should not do it
with a guy or something don't lay with a
guy I mean I think would have been an
interesting thing I you can see I'm a
biblical scholar the point is that that
was an opportunity for Cain and he
missed it and I think it would have been
a valid one and a good one um if you
were moderating the debate what question
would you ask either side of the
candidate very simply i would ask them
and i would push and i would push them
on this beyond what their package answer
would be so it would be an answer and
follow i would say why do you you
sitting in front of me right now why do
you want to be the most powerful person
in the world or the person who's one
heartbeat away from being the most
powerful person in the world what is it
about your life experience and then of
course look they're gonna give you the
my parents were coal miners and all that
stuff and then you got to push them
further where you're gonna fight you I
want to find out something about them
what is the philosophy behind I voted
this swype for this and this and that
it's like what we need to it's like why
do you why do you think you're qualified
to do this why do you what drives you to
want to be part of this awful machine
you know there's so many good people out
there that could get in politics and
good people don't want to be in politics
and that's why we end up with all this
good the average good person out there
wants nothing to do with its these days
and that's that's sad and hopefully
that'll change but I don't see it
changing anytime soon so when you so
it's not it's almost like we're only
going to get broke people we're only
going to get broken people to be part of
a broken system if we had a better
system I think we would get better
people let's see Dave any advice for a
libertarian voter at this stage in the
game I still want to support the party
but is this will actually too close well
oh here's the thing with the with
third-party things that I looted to this
all right maybe I flat out said it in my
video with Gary Johnson
obviously a third party is not going to
win it this year but for all these
people including Bernie Sanders who
basically saying voting for a third
parties throwing your vote away which is
so awful for Bernie Sanders ran with
young people and the Bernie revolution
and small donations now he's fully in on
big Wall Street money and you know all
the things they claim to hate you know
that gave him a house yes a house got a
new house and by a lake or something up
in Vermont um so I would say this um
there don't be afraid to cast your vote
for what you think is right ultimately i
would i would that would be my answer to
anyone ask me any question related to
politics if you think that Donald Trump
is the answer then vote for Donald Trump
and if you think Hillary Ben's dad are
both earned if you think gary johnson is
the answer program if you I think you
could make it even a stronger case for a
libertarian vote because they need to
get to a point where they can play ball
with the big guys and if that's why Gary
Johnson so disappointing as I just said
this was the chance this was the CH
imagine if Gary Johnson let's forget the
Aleppo moment or the stupid tongue thing
or or all of his little gaps that have
consistently happened or just in the
last day or so this thing about you know
if you don't know geography you won't
know which country to vile like and it
could have been slightly a joke okay
fine um this imagine if they had had a
strong principled libertarian standing
up there saying why we should have
smaller government why you should have
lower taxes why we shouldn't be in
military adventures all over the world
all of these things and someone who
really felt this guy knows what he's
talking well you know what at the end of
the day maybe you wouldn't have voted
for him this time but you go you know
what there's something happening here it
starts with an idea right that's what I
talked about on the show all the time
and that's why I wanted Gary Johnson in
there just so that people could hear
some other ideas one time he obviously
wasn't gonna get it second so so I would
say if you gary johnson and the
libertarians parties line up with your
beliefs the most then you got it then
vote fun and don't listen all the people
who say you know if one of the
candidates wins by one percentage point
they're gonna blame the libertarian so
they'll blame the Green Party you don't
blame the [ __ ] guy who
who blew the election that or the woman
collection um hey day why do you think
that people who don't live in swing
states even vote with the Electoral
College most states well matter yeah you
know it's an unfortunate part of our
process what's happened with the
electoral colleges you know back in the
day part of the reason for electoral
college was that you know we couldn't be
candidates couldn't travel everywhere
across the country so easily so
basically if you were running for
president why would you ever go to
Montana let's say where there's
virtually nobody there now it's like we
don't need the electoral colleges
because I you wanted Montana to be wait
a little bit more by the fact they
wanted people to actually the
presidential candidates show up there
amongst others um look so yeah we have
states now like Pennsylvania like Ohio
and like Florida and a couple others
that become the key things to it if you
only been one of those things look first
of anything can happen I think the
polling this year because of the Trump
thing is so out of whack that I don't
trust any of the polls because I think a
lot of people are afraid to say who
they're voting for and also don't they
do most polls by landlines I haven't
have a landline in 10 years when was
last time any of you were have any of
you been pulled any of you that are
watching this on youtube right now who
are probably relatively young and
tech-savvy and all that have any of you
ever been pulled for an election I never
I would love to know if any um so look
that's we gotta fix this system we gotta
fix the system that's what it all comes
down to is fixing the system more than
anything else um let's say Dave how do
you feel about the whole Russia and
Crimea thing they danced around it in
the debate should we heart be harder on
them and how do we crawl Russia so first
off Cain did you know he'd made a bunch
of straw man arguments about what Trump
said he didn't correctly point out that
Trump said that Russia is not going into
Crimea while they've been there for two
years so he was correct in that
accusation um look I just wrote my idea
and my direct message for the show that
will be up in a couple days actually not
not the show that you're going to see
naka de organism tomorrow a Wednesday
but I saw bro talking about Russia
because I it's clear to me that Russia
is going to start playing a bigger role
in the next month whether it be through
wikileaks stuff at house that can is
that connected to the russian government
or whether it's through what's going on
in Syria or the fact that Putin kills
like there's some sort of vacuum here
that he can enter into as America's sort
of seeds space in the world um you know
oddly the Democrats seem much more
hawkish on Russia who seems much more
against Russia and much more inclined to
do something military it seems like it
would be Clinton and if you listen to
what Kane said that being said is Trump
possibly cozying up to much to Putin
possibly but I think we unless you I
would have to see some conspiracy that
would show me that that was actually the
case but the point is the best way I can
answer your question is learn a little
bit now because I think over the net
mark my words on this video right now I
think over the next week's would be
hearing a lot more about Russia a lot
more about other interfering in the
election and doing military things that
we have to get involved in and it's all
gonna lead up her right to the election
so be informed about what Rush what's
going on in Russia and I should do more
myself i have my next week Cathie Jung
who he's a great wizard great journalist
and she was born in Russia lived there
until she was 16 she's coming on and
we're going to talk about it we're gonna
talk about it and be informed so that
when the media starts telling you things
about Russian off you should start
telling you things about Russia you'll
have some answers for yourself or at
least some context to what they're
saying okay let's see um this is from
someone on patreon what do you think
about canes prepackaged Ruby OS
one-liners they were terrible they were
terrible every single time and pence you
know the thing about pens is he's so
freaking calm that that that's where it
comes off as a little instance here
because it's like show a little emotion
I'm not the most emotional person on
earth so I get it um but when when he
tried to zing him back like oh you
prepare that one well oh there's that
line again or how many times you said
that he's just too sleepy to do it
effectively but I think most people were
thinking yeah Cain congratulations you
said another line but you've said a
thousand times you off er um let's see
Dave how do you feel about direct
democracy are we too ignorant to be
trusted so I assume by direct democracy
just talked about one person one vote
where guess once wrote in the period um
I think it's very hard to change a
system so drastically that's existed for
so long and as screwy as our system is
say it screwed up all of that I think
there are incremental ways to change it
to make it better but you know if you
tried something that was so profoundly
different who knows what comes out on
the other side that's not necessarily an
argument completely against it but I
think we do have to be leery of we have
something that's pretty good here and
something that as I say all time you
know that most people on earth are very
jealous of most people even when they
there you know in Europe when they're
rocking America they kind of do miss
some of our liberty and our jealous of
our free speech and you know certain
things that we have here so I would be
leery of changing everything so quickly
also I guess at some level there is a
risk that then the mob could fully be in
charge of everything at once and there's
a risk in that and the way that our you
know there's a beauty to our
Constitution and I hope you guys had a
chance to watch my show with Randy
Barnett constitutional law professor at
Georgetown about two weeks ago where we
really dug into why the Constitution is
such a great document why our separation
of powers and why they're so effective
and why our checks and balances work and
all of these things and that the
executive branch is getting more
powerful and more powerful and more
powerful that's not the way it's
supposed to work but every president
sucks more power out and we got to watch
out for it let's see um somebody's again
Phil DeFranco on to talk about YouTube
Heroes program so do you guys see this
thing this is a little bit we can get
away from the debate also if you want
we'll be right back back and forth you
wanna smother things I don't you guys
saw this but there is this big thing the
YouTube Heroes program where they want
regular people watching YouTube to be
heroes into mess flag videos you don't
like and warn them about language and
all this other crap and they had a ton
of [ __ ] for it last I saw it had
something like maybe 10,000 likes and
500,000 dislikes um bill told Franco was
talking about it my friend chris ray gun
and a whole bunch of other people were
mocking it yeah that talk about the
mob being in charge why would you allow
just everybody to start mass flagging
things that just because they're
offended or they don't like the language
or whatever what you'd end up doing is
Maki in effect be creating a system that
incentivizes people to shut down free
speech the more things you shut down
knew there was gonna be a point system i
mean really awful and misguided stuff
yes the road to hell is paved with good
intentions but you got to watch out for
those intention um let's see to either
these choices stand the chance in a
second term at their age that's a great
question Trump is 70 Hillary 69 without
being conspiratorial there are issues
related to Hillary's health it's fairly
obvious that video on 911 he truly
collapsed maybe it was a combination of
being sick and being on medication and
it was hot out and exhaustion and all of
that stuff that be said she full on that
wasn't a stumble and wasn't a trip her
body was lifeless and limp and they
carried into car so it is some
relationship from he's been eating rich
food this whole life he could have gout
you gotta watch out for that they closed
the rich person's disease I think they
called yeah um so look at 74 they'd both
be 74 basically by the end of the first
term a 74 year old uh there's probably a
lot of reasons not that 70 74 you'd
still be in the prime of life doing all
kinds of great things with your
retirement years yeah you have a whole
life ahead of you and with technology
and everything else I mean I have Zoltan
is run on the show tomorrow whose
transhumanist talking about medicine and
technology he I think he said that he
believes there are people right now like
ray girls while you guys probably know
who's written about singularity at
Google who believes he's gonna live
forever and he's alive right now so I
don't want to get hung up on the number
as much as this could have been an
important duo that we saw tonight
because perhaps something could happen
to one of these candidates and
forgetting that that the country so
polarized that i would i would venture
to say that either one of them will be a
one-term president that would be my
guess um hey day you said we can't
change the system profoundly but we can
do you think the constitutional
convention
would be a good thing it personally
scares me but I think we need so yes of
course I'm not saying we can there there
this is our beautiful Constitution is
they wrote in ways that you can
drastically alter the system what I'm
saying is I don't know that a system has
lasted as long as ours with all the
success ours has and then suddenly
changed in a very profound way for the
better i could be wrong if I am it on
please please let me know so we could
have a constitutional convention and
really try to change some things
massively I don't know that I would
necessarily be against that it's clear
after this election whoever wins we got
we got to really change some things we
need better public discourse we really
strongly need better education because
that's what everything comes down to not
just our election process but every
social issue that we're having an
economic issue in everything comes down
to education a smart society of people
won't get caught in the easy tracks that
the media and politicians want to track
you it we also need either public
funding of elections or more than
anything else if you're watching this
right now after this election how about
you don't give money to a politician
anymore I mean anybody all those people
that gave all that money to Bernie
Bernie in effect now is it not in fact
he's back at you know it was an
incredible amount of mainstream Wall
Street all of that money right so don't
give any of them their money you have to
starvin that's what I was talking about
in my video at Gary Johnson is put these
guys on alert there is nothing in our
Constitution that says we can only have
two parties we should have more parties
and it should be funded publicly so
they're on equal footing and there will
always be cheaters and there will always
be ways to cheat but we can we can do
better but starve them of money stop
going right now you think about this
Obama has what four months left on his
presidency or so something like that
think how many more fundraisers he's
going to go to her the course that many
for thirty thousand dollar a head or
whatever now I get it those people rub
elbows with them they want power and all
that stuff um no stop giving the money
it's the only way that's gonna ever stop
anything okay let's see um Oh somebody
that we just gave away the internet
works
Rudy I'm the big thing this week I can I
mean basically we bomb a seated control
the internet to the United Nations which
didn't get much play at all
unfortunately it got virtually no play
on mainstream media it's unclear to me
exactly how this is going to affect the
Internet I hope not much but you know
now that's controlled by the UN the UN
is a hugely corrupt organization that
does some good things but does a lot of
bad things too and now countries like
China and Saudi Arabian plenty of other
countries with terrible human rights
violations that don't that aren't a
subject to our First Amendment of free
speech are going to have more control
over the Internet and the United States
is going to have blessed this thing's
been chugging along pretty well the
internet it has changed the world it has
had massive effect on connecting people
and connecting us right now and causing
revolutions in Egypt and all kinds of
other games so did it need to be fixed
or handed away I don't think so so I
think it was a bad thing I hope I'm
wrong about that um David think a
centrist same party could emerge from
this I hope so I hope so and that's why
I want that's why I want more pardons
because I think what could happen if you
took the left right and you said are
Democrats at the Democrats split in half
so you'd have the sort of more
mainstream Democrats meaning like the
Hillary wake up look whether you like
Hillary or not and then you have the
progressive so I would say the far left
if they split into two and then you took
the right and you had the mainstream
Republicans now I guess that would be
that I would consider that the Trump
version of it right now and then you
have the Libertarians the small
government guys and maybe it's three
parties for their maybe it's the Trump
people the conservatives and
libertarians actually they could be
splitting it three that I think what you
would find is that the people in the
center the centrist democrats in the
centrist conservatives Republicans
whatever you want um they would come
together and you would have a new party
a party filled with people based on
logic and reason that would say we don't
have to agree on it we don't have to
agree anything but we can we can try to
find some answers together and not
demonize everybody that's what we
desperately need and I think it's
possible that we'll get it after this
but there's what people have to stay
engaged after this thing you know I know
that election feels like it sometimes
but it's
on at some level and all that um but you
know the question is what happens after
does everyone just feel like this has
been like this year long like suck fest
and we're just all exhausted after or
will people say a gauge I hope it's the
latter obviously um why didn't cain't
bring up Pence's distaste for sign it so
look Kane I guess I was a little light
on pence but it was Kane's fault because
he didn't bring up any of the sign stuff
which he should have and he didn't bring
up any of the LGBT stuff which he
absolutely should those would have been
clear issues that the average person
that's somewhat of a centrist and even a
moderate Republican that believes in
science and guess what they do exist and
a moderate Republican that believes in
gay rights and guess what they exist to
would have not been pleased with Pence's
answers on to that stuff so came really
missed an opportunity on I think he did
he really dropped it I'm nothing was
waiting for the waiting for the
moderator to do it or what um alright
this is from patreon as a non-american
I'm interested in how invested you are
in the electoral college it seems to me
from a small country of Sweden if you
elect someone for a federal position
every vote chewy equal so I kind of
talked about this already so if you're
just jumping on now just back up about
10 or 15 minutes there are there are
reasons that having such a giant country
and the fear of being ruled by the mob
basically is the reason we have it the
electoral system is very flawed and not
don't not only that but let's not forget
that our political parties have flawed
processes which is why the Democrats
have super-delegates because they wanted
to make sure that they could override
the will of the people if they have you
the Republicans don't even have that
Republicans have some other things in
place where things could go to second
and third fourth ballots etc etc but
those are not legal things that have
anything to our Constitution those are
Hardy things so we have to get the power
away from the parties and hand it back
to the people that's a lot Pete um do
you see millennial party popping up over
the next four years bored of disgruntled
Bernie supporters and neocon Democrats
not reflecting their values Millennials
on pace to be the largest voting group
that's a good one I mean all of the
questions all the stuff you guys are
asking about third-party all comes down
to how engaged people want to be so if
Millennials want to be the first
generation in a while to say [ __ ] this
we gotta get our voices heard we gotta
start a new party and we don't like this
wing of the Democratic Party because of
Hillary and we don't like this wing of
the Republican Party because of Trump
and if no alternative shows up and that
there was a real younger party I think
that would be interesting look there's
also a risk and having signed that was
really the millennial party of young
people because as a general rule I think
older people can give us wisdom and
people that have lived beyond us and
seeing things change in history does
repeat itself so I think you know a
party that was just designed for young
people there's a certain risk in that
and I think that was a little bit of my
problem with the Bernie stuff because it
was a little bit based on feelings not
necessarily facts you know like the free
college think it sounds great and if I
had been going to college this year I
would have been screaming for free
college but somebody does have to pay
for it so you know there's a lot of
stuff like that but yeah I think
anything that brings more voices in
would it would be good um Nate when you
say the left and the right can you
explain them in your own words so I
should have done more on this in general
because I do say these words a lot
people ask me a lot and they need
different things in different countries
and I didn't even realize that so much
until this past year where I hear it
from people always that it means a
little something different if you're in
the UK and it needs to learn different
if you're in canada and plenty of other
places generally speaking in America
what it means is if you're on the left
your thought of it as liberal meaning
generally you're socially you're
socially open you're socially liberal
right even so if your thought you your
forgets or for whatever thought to be
women's rights you're pro-choice things
like that a gem also what that comes
with for a series of reasons is bigger
government because you want government
to do those things you want government
to give gay people or certain rights you
want government to protect the right of
for women to choose and etc etc so it's
sort of bigger government and
socially liberal and on the right it's
not of conservative don't change things
that fast have a certain respect for
what happened in front of you and you
should be for smaller government and for
states rights generally that's the left
right thing in America it's different in
all kinds of countries as a general rule
I've always thought of myself as someone
on the left because I'm liberal so if
you were to go through every liberal
talking point that there is usually I
line up with those little things what's
happening unfortunately is that the left
is becoming ill liberal so they haven't
really been for logic and reason and
they haven't really been tolerant of the
other and they put everybody in this
oppression Olympics thing that we talked
about all the time these are not liberal
ideas and unfortunately I in some ways I
find myself agreeing more with moderate
conservatives that I find myself
agreeing with people on left actually I
shouldn't say that's unfortunate i don't
find it but it's just an interesting
place to be and we're seeing the fringes
on both sides get further and i think
that that is to go to a question that
was couple before I think that is
welcome cause sort of a new center
situation so there you go I'm um you
know I did this last week but so right
now I'm why I got CNN on the back they
have the Clinton campaign chairman John
Podesta wonder you think he's saying
Kane or Penn State better what do you
think i'm gonna guess he said that came
did better now quick let's see what's
going on on fox you think that they
might have something similar happening
right now you've got megan kelly and she
is talking to a Hillary Clinton campaign
spokesman this guy i think is named John
Messina maybe i'm gonna guess he's
saying that tim kaine did better then
let's go over to MSNBC and it's chuck
todd and i'm going to guess he's saying
Tim Kaine doing better too because we
know who you're voting for Chuck Todd I
don't see we saw victory just yet
because it's just a min um alright let's
see I you know it will not get a couple
more questions and then I think we're
going to cut this one a little short
because it was it was relatively
uneventful but you know I always welcome
your comments I
hearing from you guys like when you push
back on me in a fair way um when you
just yeah he's a [ __ ] idiot that
[ __ ] [ __ ] dad dad don't you know I
don't get much from that but the other
is the others I totally enjoy it I love
having these conversations with you guys
um let's see oh I should mention before
I wrap up give you a moment for the last
couple questions here you guys know we
are fan funded so if you want to join us
on patreon and we do all kinds of things
with t-shirts and mugs and one-on-one
hangouts and Google Hangouts and a whole
bunch of other stuff and there's a
patreon app where i chat with people and
like whatsapp kind of thing it's
patreon.com/scishow been report and if
you want to make a one-time donation to
show and help us build it out if you did
what we're doing it's rupon before tom /
donate and I will knock out just a
couple more somebody said I can't see
how the whole internet would suffer
under UN control internet providers and
countries who are not gain we're not
game for limiting net neutrality and
imposing century center [ __ ] we'll
continue to resist it I guess purely at
the intellectual level probably what you
said is correct the issue is that what
happens the UN has a lot of countries
that do a lot of bad things that are in
positions of power Libya and Syria or
Saudi Arabia have both been on the Human
Rights Council as chair chair countries
so they've done some strange things
there the bigger point would be that the
Internet's can work not a good time
warner but besides if you have time line
the Internet's basically been working so
why did we decide to make this move it
just seems like we put ourselves in a
precarious position for no reason so
about that would be my everything uh
let's say Dave who is who does Trump
parallel in the Star Wars universe if
Clinton is Palpatine let's see well if
Clinton is Palpatine I think that's a
that's a bit of a jump but I've seen
that picture it's a great picture of
Clinton is probably there Clinton let me
think for a second here who would
trumped be who would Trumpy well by
rhetoric alone right by just by rhetoric
he has to be someone on the dark side
[Music]
I'm trying to think of something clever
with immigration hear something with
immigration related to Ewoks
um who would Trump be Trump I see well
know who's Trump Trump's Jabba the Hutt
right Trump is java hut me similar skin
tone and you know he's running his big
palace and he's got a bunch of
sycophants around him and he has
expensive things hanging on the wall
like carpet I'd han Solo so Trump his
job at a hut and Hilary Hilary sort of
good turned evil but maybe could turn
good at the end does that make her dark
Vader I don't know Palpatine was purely
evil I don't think Clint it was purely
like evil evil um somebody said do you
get the full amount that is donated from
patreon they take a very small
percentage I think maybe it's five
percent ish yeah it's a small percentage
so we do get the bulk of it and you guys
have given us a budget to do the show as
we see fit we got a couple interesting
things coming over the next few weeks
that I'm going to announce soon and I'm
excited to tell you guys about a few
ways that we're going to try to expand
the show and some other things that
we're going to do you know these we
launched fan funded in June really
didn't start the show til July so it's
only been you know what three four
months and we had to get our business
set or health insurance and do stuff
with a company and a lot of stuff that I
I'd rather someone else dew point is we
got all my ire now now and now we can
figure out out of its fan and we hugely
appreciate you guys could have jumped in
and do that okay and many people are
saying that Trump is Jar Jar Binks um
these morons more job come on he's more
job you can't see Trump with melania
like with a little chain around her neck
sitting there and he's eating my brother
okay that was my job impression not
great um all right I think we're going
to an I'll do I'll do one last one on a
hopeful note that this is sort of a team
tonight advice for first time and young
voters vote get your voice heard
something like forty percent of
Americans vote and that's in a good
election get out there and be hurried if
this is frustrating to you and you don't
understand why we've been left in this
situation then go be hurt and to end
more than anything else and maybe even
more than voting although that is very
important don't be afraid to share what
you think it's okay to be wrong
sometimes it's okay to have your mind
change but don't be
afraid to share what you think because
your your thoughts are as valid as
anyone elses and yes you are going to
change I'm sure there's a litany as I've
said many times I've been liberal since
I was in seventh grade and I first heard
the term and I thought that's what I am
a liberal person sort of looking out for
others but my thoughts have evolved and
a lot of the things that I can argue why
I'm for is a liberal like now or before
as from a libertarian perspective as
well which is why I'm or consider myself
a classical liberal which is very much
in line with libertarianism but again
let's not get too caught up and in the
terms but we don't be afraid to be heard
if you're not a bigot don't be afraid
when your friend calls you up and don't
befriend people lose friends over this
stuff try to be out there and put
yourself out there and be brave and a
lot of people are saying that we should
expand the show we're working on it but
if you want to help us do it Ruben
report.com session donate anyway it's
been fun as always thank you guys we got
a new episode drop in tomorrow I
mentioned my guest before Zoltan is fun
who's he's actually running his
president for like a third third third
third party called the transhumanist
party obviously not going to win it this
time but a really interesting guy and
it's all about a science and medicine
and how technology can change us and
that those are the issues of the future
that we can talk anything about AI or
medical science or cloning or any of
these think they're gonna be so massive
in very in short amount of time are
going to Mars or all this up there
bickering and we can set this it's like
Oh grow up anyway thanks guys been fun
and we'll do it again soon okay